the establishment media have had enough
okay it was fine
it was all right on election night for
nobody to pick a winner because you know
they still had to
increase joe biden's vote count by a lot
overnight and then in the ensuing days
but now look it's been several days more
than several days
and donald trump and his terrible family
and his rotten appointees they've all
just got to concede okay and why do they
have to concede because
jake tapper says so the response or lack
thereof from republican officials when
it comes to the untethered and wild
allegations being made
by the president and his spawn and his
supporters uh about
the uh election all the crazy and false
claims about it being stolen
you should check out the the the twitter
feed of the president's
spawn because it is like rantings in
cram by somebody having an lsd trip i
mean is somebody
these are these are claims that are just
so wild
um that they wouldn't even make forget
fox they wouldn't even make fox business
where you know
where all sorts of facts go to die
that's very serious journalist jake
tapper he's a very serious man that's
why he refers to the president's
children as spawn
and that's why he wants you to know the
claims of fraud they're wild
they're crazy they're totally untrue and
that's why you definitely shouldn't look
into any of them
don't look into what went on in
pennsylvania and definitely don't look
into
what happened in wisconsin because
nothing happened with wisconsin what are
we talking about fraud what fraud i
don't see any fraud
move along move along ain't nothing to
see here actually there is something to
see here
we'll go through all the facts as we
have them i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday comes from joe
mann who says i'm really scared of dying
now
since i don't want to vote democrat no
you know
generally we should have no fear of
death certainly christians should have
no fear of death as we
anticipate our eternal reward and the
beatific vision
but the only only downside then would be
that you are much
much more likely to vote democrat after
you have shuffled off this mortal coil
than than right now particularly in some
of these democrat-run machine cities
and machine states though jake tapper
would deny that
i was reminded watching this clip that
jake tapper is just
awful he's just awful you know they try
to position jake tapper
he is the reasonable one he's the
moderate one okay he'll hold
democrats feet to the fire he's got that
kind of grizzled face
you know and he he's serious and he'll
say it like it is
no i don't think he will he refers to
the president's children as spawn
and now he's threatening any republican
of any kind who refuses to concede this
election before the legal process
plays out he's threatening their
livelihoods their careers
because that's what the establishment
media exists to do they exist
to bully you to hide information and to
push
their own narrative he's trying to put
people in a very precarious professional
situation
you don't want to put yourself in that
kind of a situation though so you got to
check out lifelock working from home
has some serious challenges okay hotels
are advertising daytime room
reservations for guests seeking quiet
distraction-free family-free work
environments
but according to the fbi accessing
sensitive information from hotel wi-fi
poses an increased security risk over
home wi-fi networks
hackers can exploit lax hotel wi-fi
security to steal
work and personal data it is very
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives you know we we just don't think
about it too much
because it's kind of technologically
advanced and you think no one wants your
data
they do and lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats like for
instance your social security number
for sale on the dark web i i used to
not worry about any of this stuff oh
data it's okay
it's no big deal nobody wants my stuff
and then i've seen what happens when
people have their identities stolen
it is so awful do you gotta prevent it
obviously no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions
at all businesses but lifelock and see
threats that you might miss on your own
join now and save up to 25
off your first year go to lifelock.com
knowles canadawlas
that is lifelock.com noel skinner wlas
for 25
off you're going to need the savings
because jake tapper
wants to ruin your career jake tapper
tweets out
quote i truly sympathize with those
dealing with losing
it's not easy but at a certain point one
has to think
not only about what's best for the
nation peaceful transfer of power
but how any future employers might see
your character
divined during adversity so
listen buddy that's a nice job you got
there sure would be a shame if something
happened to it
i truly sympathize he does
jake does he didn't seem to sympathize
or rather i suppose he sympathized too
much with the people
who lost in 2016 who never gave up the
election he seemed to sympathize
i think he still sympathizes with them
but he seems to have lost some sympathy
for all of us who want the legal process
to play out
bush v gore took 38 days
to push recounts in one state that was
totally fine according to jake tapper
but now waiting for the legal process to
play out for how many days has it been
it's been five days or something like
that that's too much for tapper and look
it's not just about the good of the
nation
well you know it's about your career too
i'll tell you what jake
i truly sympathize with those
establishment media hacks trying to rush
us past
the legal process here and not have
anyone look too closely into what
happened in philadelphia
maybe in wisconsin maybe in arizona
maybe nevada
i truly sympathize with them they don't
want any nefarious actions from election
officials to come out
but i think right now one has to think
about how this is going to end in the
courts
one way or the other maybe the courts
give it to biden maybe the courts give
it to trump
but this is not going to end because the
mainstream
how mainstream were they the
establishment media tell us
that it will not just cnn showing their
cards right now by the way
cnn remember cnn used to be the central
centrist center-left cable network msnbc
was the left-wing one
fox news was the right-wing one then
during the trump era cnn became the
furthest left-wing
cable news outlet msnbc was still a
validly left wing
but they were just more honest and
actually less hysterical about it
and fox news remained right-wing though
it had moved
significantly more to the center well
now fox news is leading the charge to
kick trump out of office
so there was a fox news reporter sandra
smith
i have i've been on her show she's
always been very nice to me
sandra smith was caught on a hot mic
though uh
muttering under her breath at how
outrageous it is that trump campaign is
still
still going along and pushing and trying
to win this election
because fox news already called the race
remember just because cnn says or even
fox news says that somebody's present
doesn't make them president so i think
everybody
wants to know that this was done
properly and legally
what is happening and i think we have to
look into
every one of these concerns yeah i think
yeah and i think clearly makes a very
good point there steve so sandra
obviously
thought that the microphone in the
camera had cut away from her and she
thought she was just on a closed mic to
trace gallagher and said
come on trace what's going on here now
what's what's interesting about this
i i don't i don't know sandra smith all
that well you know
did the show a bit but uh i i don't know
that her
outrage is coming necessarily because
she's a radical leftist or something
like that
i i think she's expressing a view that
a lot of journalists are expressing
right now which is
the indignation that they have called
the race
and the trump campaign is not willing to
allow the the media
to call the race because of course in
our constitutional system
the media do not decide who wins
presidential elections
the states certify winners and then the
electoral college votes
and it doesn't matter if cnn or msnbc or
even fox news
calls the race they're not the ones who
get to decide
and so i think sandra's indignation that
she's expressing here
is a representative of a lot of
journalists who say what
we called it we did it how dare you not
accept
that we in the media have called this
election and sandra is certainly not the
only person at fox
who has been hammering the trump
campaign not even close
chris wallace who you may recall
moderated the worst presidential debate
in american history
and uh it was it was a dece i mean he
was
i think the worst moderator ever and and
i don't know what it is about trump
because i've enjoyed watching his
interview shows before
chris wallace he's he's always been much
fairer than people on cnn or msnbc
but i don't know there was just
something about trump where he was
interrupting all of the time
it was a disastrous debate they got bad
reviews from everybody
chris wallace is now saying that that
president trump
and the people in the republican party
defending him
are ridiculous they're soldiering on
like people who don't realize
that the war is over dana it would seem
to me that republicans on
capitol hill have a role to play in this
a very few of them have said
look you pursue your legal options but
uh
you know damp down the rhetoric like
mitt romney like pat
toomey uh there are a lot who are just
silent
and then there are some i mentioned ted
cruz
uh you know who who are like the
japanese soldiers who come out
uh 30 years after the end of the of the
war
and uh out of the jungle and say you
know is the fight still going on
what do you expect the mood to be inside
uh senate republicans you know as they
begin to think perhaps their future is
no longer
so directly tied to donald trump well
also remember the senate republicans
were counted out
i i love dana parino just gives a
straight answer
even as she's being baited by chris
wallace over there
we're one week from the election there
were no
results on election night no results
today real clear politics still hasn't
called the race
real clear politics which is a very
reliable source you know it kind of
takes in information
from all of the news sources
still haven't called it the media don't
call it generally no state has certified
a winner
so no i i don't think it's like the
japanese soldier who 30 years after the
war
comes out of the woods and thinks the
war is still on notice what chris
wallace says he goes
why can't republicans be like mitt
romney
who conceded the race on trump's behalf
immediately
why do they all have to be like ted cruz
what's the difference between mitt
romney and ted cruz that sounds like
the start to a joke it sounds like a
setup maybe you can come up with the
punch line
the the straight answer is mitt romney
is a liberal republican and ted cruz is
a conservative republican
and that's what it's about and when the
media use these terms like the spawn
of donald trump and the soldiers in the
in the jungles after world war ii these
foolish idiots 30 years after the war
what they're really saying is
it's okay to be a liberal republican and
it's evil and terrible to be a
conservative republican
and that is the view now being pushed by
every single establishment media outlet
every single one without exception i
think you
catch my drift it's not even
the mockery it's not even just the snide
comments at this point
all of the establishment networks are
actually cutting off cutting away from
undermining
the elected and appointed officials of
this administration
that is a very scary story not as scary
though as the story from wondering that
you should check out
imagine you're a parent nervously pacing
around your injured child's hospital
room
a doctor begins asking you question
after question about how your kid got
hurt
then as he's asking these questions you
begin to realize they're asking about
your involvement in the accident where
were you when he fell how did he
actually fall
and then you slowly start to see that
they think that you hurt your child
intentionally
wondering and nbc news present do no
harm
the terrifying true story of a family
torn apart by
the system that was supposed to protect
them investigative reporter mike
hixenbau chronicles what happens to the
bright family
after their three kids are ripped away
from them and the shocking moments that
came next
with exclusive audio captured as the
events unfolded do no harm
takes you inside the most harrowing
moments of the bright families fight
to protect their children subscribe to
do no harm on apple podcasts
join wonder plus in the wondery app to
listen one week early
and ad free very scary story and the
scary political story now
is that the establishment media have no
respect
whatsoever for our elected and appointed
officials
because i think generally speaking the
media believe they know better
and so they'll allow this democracy
thing this republic thing
to play out every so often but once
they've decided enough is enough
well enough is enough so neil cavuto
also on fox news committed an absolutely
unforgivable act the other day
kaylee mcenany the press secretary who
makes all of our hearts go pitter-patter
she was giving a press conference
describing
in detail what was going on the the many
irregularities at these polling places
and i i almost can't even say it neil
cavuto cut away from cayley
ten thousand swords should leap from
their scabbards to avenge even an
insulting glance
from a established media journalist much
less
cutting her off mid-sentence i was
furious take a listen
there is only one party in america
trying to keep observers out of the
count room
and that party my friends is the
democrat party
you don't take these positions because
you want an honest election
you don't oppose an audit of the vote
because you want an accurate count
you don't oppose our efforts at sunlight
and transparency because you have
nothing to hide
you take these positions because you are
welcoming fraud and you are welcoming
illegal voting our position is clear
we want to protect the franchise of the
american people
we want an honest accurate lawful count
we want maximum sunlight we want maximum
transparency we want every legal vote to
be counted
and we want every illegal vote well i
just think we have to be very clear
she's charging up the other side is
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this i want to make sure
that maybe they do have something to
back that up
but that's an explosive charge to make
the other side is effectively
rigging and cheating it's an explosive
charge
it's it's outrageous unless she's got
evidence to back that up and i don't
know what the evidence is because i'm
just a journalist
so i i obviously haven't looked into
this at all well you know actually
if any of the journalists would open
their eyes and and
if they could stop uh lavishing praise
on joe biden for one second
and stop congratulating the
president-elect joe biden for just one
second
you'd see a lot of evidence a lot of
evidence of fraud and irregularities now
that doesn't mean that the the evidence
of fraud and irregularities
is enough to change the result of the
election we don't know that's what the
legal process
is for but to say that there is no
evidence whatsoever that is
crazy that is simply ignorant ronna
mcdaniel who is the head of the rnc
and a michigan native she outlined just
a little bit of the evidence that they
found in michigan
poll watchers are pull election workers
blocked windows and padlock doors
obviously that's that's not going to
instill confidence um there are
thousands of reports of poll watchers
being intimidated and unable to do their
job
and as of 4 pm this afternoon 131
affidavits have been completed just in
michigan
with over 2 800 incident reports that
have been submitted
to us since election day two new
lawsuits were filed today by people who
were working who were working
in detroit and a whistleblower who has
gotten their information we have gotten
their information to the eastern
district court of michigan
as you guys can understand with 2800
incident reports
this is a lot to track down it means
we're interviewing these people we're
getting their statements and we're
turning them into affidavits
in addition to that we've heard hundreds
of instances of election workers who
were verbally accosted
are pulled they verbally accosted our
poll watchers and refusals to let them
challenge questionable ballots election
workers were wearing biden t-shirts
and applauding when our poll watchers
were kicked out
2 800 incident reports 100 what was it
she said 130 some odd
affidavits already sworn affidavits
we already knew i guess uh neil and some
of the other
establishment journalists didn't know
that republican poll watchers were not
permitted
to watch the polls and then
at least in philadelphia there's a court
order saying you have to let them watch
you know what you know what happened
they still were not permitted to watch
the polls
what's that about that to me seems like
quite a lot of evidence of
wrongdoing irregularities use whatever
euphemism you want
what were they hiding and then in
michigan
thousands of incident reports well
how many votes does that affect maybe it
affects no votes
maybe it's all a big misunderstanding
but if it is a big misunderstanding
we're going to need to let that play out
in court before all of you
in the establishment press and
establishment technology and
establishment higher education
and establish and the liberal
establishment itself before you all
start
popping bottles of vove to celebrate
celebrate
joe biden's apparent victory what
evidence do we have that's an explosive
charge
okay you just heard from ronna talking
michigan wide how about in detroit
there's a detroit elections worker named
jesse jacob
who testified that a supervisor ordered
him to back date
absentee ballots you know throughout
these states
and we all called this the minute we
heard about widespread unsolicited
mail-in votes
said there's going to be this problem of
fraud not even that necessarily it's
hundreds of thousands of dead people
voting or that it's hundreds of
thousands of people voting who aren't
supposed to be voting
but even in the case of people who do
have the right to vote
if they don't vote by the deadline that
is an illegal vote that vote cannot be
counted
if it is counted then the worker who
counted the ballot has committed a crime
if it's systemic then you've got major
corruption in the election system
and we know for a fact that there has
been long-standing corruption
in major democratic cities like
philadelphia like detroit
like all of the places that are being
contested right now so
jesse jacobs says a supervisor told him
to back date absentee ballots he says
quote
i processed absentee ballot packages to
be sent to voters
while i worked at the election
headquarters in september 2020
along with 70 to 80 other poll workers i
was instructed by my supervisor to
adjust the mailing date of these
absentee ballot packages
to be dated earlier than they were
actually sent
the supervisor was making announcements
for all workers
to engage in this practice then further
i directly observed on a
daily basis city of detroit election
workers and employees
coaching and trying to coach voters to
vote for
joe biden and the democrat party i
witnessed these workers
and employees encouraging voters to do a
straight
democrat ballot that obviously
extraordinarily
illegal i witnessed these election
workers and employees
going over to the voting booths with
voters
in order to watch them vote and coach
them
for whom to vote that's one guy but we
have
sworn affidavit here testimony of what
was going on in detroit
was it just that instance was it just
those 80 poll workers
okay so 80 poll workers how many ballots
did they
influence how many ballots did they back
date how many i don't know let's say
could it be uh a hundred probably more
than a hundred maybe a thousand
i don't know could it be two thousand
three thousand how many
is it enough to swing an election was it
just these poll workers
or were there many more are there 137
sworn affidavits just
in michigan alone what about outside of
michigan pennsylvania
lindsey graham just received sworn
affidavit from a postal worker in erie
pennsylvania
this is what that postal worker says
quote although
as i understand pennsylvania law ballots
must be postmarked by 8 pm on election
day
november 3rd 2020 in pennsylvania
postmaster rob weisenbach directed my
co-workers
and i to pick up ballots after
election day and provide them to him
now consider this for a second
the ballots have to be postmarked by by
november 3rd
election day the postmaster says
i want you to go out there pick up all
those extra ballots that are now
illegal ballots just bring them to me
why would he do that do we think first
of all that those
those ballots are being collected to
help trump were to help biden
philly's pretty pretty uh pretty blue
city i don't know about
erie generally something tells me though
this was brought in to help the vote
count for biden just a
just a hunch again i'm just going on my
gut here so
this postmaster gets the ballots why
does he request them
why is he willing to put himself out
there to commit a crime
after the election day is it because he
just loves joe biden that much maybe
because it could be
or is it because there's some machine at
play that he's being offered something
here to do this
i don't know i just don't know only way
to find out
take it to court this uh whistleblower
goes on in his sworn affidavit
i heard weisenbach tell a supervisor in
my office that weisenbach was back
dating the
postmarks on the ballots to make it
appear as though the ballots had been
collected on november 3rd 2020
despite them in fact being collected on
november 4th and possibly later
why are the counts still going on why
why why haven't they certified alaska at
this why haven't they called alaska
i don't isn't that weird i think i'll
ask is pretty much for trump
why not call it why did everything take
so long why did they stop counting on
election night why in some cases
did they say they stopped counting on
election night but they kept counting in
the middle of the night why did all the
biden ballots come in in the middle of
the night
why did they take a day off in some
places and then start counting later
why were they buying so much time was it
because
ballots were coming in after the
election and they wanted to see how many
they needed
i don't know i'm just asking questions
we do know that there are in many places
more registered voters than eligible
voters that's just a fact
can't fact check me on that one if you
do you'll find out it's true
a report was just issued this is from
judicial watch
indicating that among 353 u.s counties
1.8 million more voters may have
been registered than eligible voting age
citizens
1.8 million some people are saying
there's no way trump can overcome the
difference now between his votes and
bidens because biden has something like
two million more votes something like
that
well first of all he doesn't have to he
needs to overcome little margins of
eight thousand to twenty thousand maybe
fifty thousand in certain places
a lot different than two million but
also
turns out we've got almost two million
extra voters on the rolls
who are not eligible they're just
registered now in normal years
even with some use of mail-in ballots
that wouldn't pose a problem or it would
pose a minor problem
because you still have to request the
absentee ballot in normal years
not this year this year the ballots just
got sent out
sent out to everybody maybe you changed
your address but you didn't change it
with the election board
well then someone's going to get your
ballot maybe you died
maybe you are not eligible anymore
doesn't matter the ballots went out 1.8
million of them
in 353 u.s county that's just according
to this one report
from judicial watch we don't know how
widespread in in practice the problem
actually was
now that that statewide registration
exceeding 100
includes alaska i still haven't called
it i guess colorado
okay maine okay maryland
michigan michigan very important state
jersey jersey's going to go democrat
anyway rhode island vermont
same thing michigan though let's just
take michigan very important state
it doesn't matter though right because
neil cavuto doesn't know about any of
that
he hasn't he hasn't googled it i don't
know he hasn't
read the report from judicial watch he
he probably hasn't been listening to
kaylee mcinney or ronnie mcdaniel
because he can't bear it he wants to
turn off the press conferences
jake tapper says wild claims being made
by the spawn
of donald trump you're going to lose you
you're going to lose your job if you
don't concede this election
says jake tapper well much much more
serious people
than the journalists in the
establishment press are looking into
this not just judicial watch not just
rana and kaylee
also the attorney general we are very
pleased to report that the honey badger
attorney general bill barr himself has
come out and directed u.s attorneys
to pursue significant allegations of
voting irregularities
this is great news one because it's
acknowledging
there were voting irregularities we
don't know quite how widespread they
were
but they were significant much much
much more significant than anything we
have seen at least in my lifetime
probably since going back to tammany
hall or going back to
lbj stealing that senate seat in texas
back in 1948.
so that's great on the one front you got
the doj acknowledging that really
happened
but then on the other you see billboard
is being careful here he doesn't want to
appear irregular himself so he says
serious allegations should be handled
with great care
species speculative fanciful or
far-fetched claims should not be a basis
for initiating federal inquiries
they're saying look if it's some wild
accusation there's no evidence for it
or it's a very minor allegation that
really wouldn't have swung anything
we're not going to spend federal
resources on that but for significant
claims of fraud with evidence we're
going to investigate very thoroughly
this is pretty important
i've noticed especially watching jay
tapper but watching people on the left
like him or watching even some people on
the right
people are very impassioned right now
and and i understand why i mean
especially on the right because the
people on the right think that the
election was stolen
you'll notice i have not been quite as
impassioned
quite as screaming from the rooftops
making big claims and
i am making the same claims now that i
made a month before the election
which is namely the mail-in ballots have
posed this
singular problem the crooked cities such
as philadelphia and detroit have posed a
singular problem
we're not we didn't know on election
night who the winner was we still don't
know who the winner of the election is
it's going to go to court the legal
process is going to play out
this has happened before in american
history it will happen again in american
history
and the courts will decide who wins and
people still might not be happy with
that and they might say the courts
didn't do enough or they might say the
courts did too much
but that is the way the process will be
playing out
one way or another and so we want to be
cool headed here we want to be patient
as the left is screaming call him the
president-elect
paul biden the president we have to tune
those guys out
we have to be careful too on the right
because the right might say
look at this explosive evidence of some
fraud you say okay i'm going to look at
it
but i'm not going to just accept it you
know and get my hopes up necessarily
because
if that full support or even if it was
true but there's no way to prove it
that's not going to affect the outcome
in the end we are in a very
precarious situation right now the only
thing we can do
is wait we can stand by the president
first of all we cannot refer to joe
biden as the president-elect i think
it's preposterous
and silly liberal republicans like mitt
romney court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism
ought to be ashamed of themselves for
doing that we shouldn't do that neither
should we pop champagne ourselves and
say trump's getting reelected
necessarily
we're in a precarious holding pattern
and we're going to know a lot more next
week once that legal process
is playing out in the meantime though
cocaine mitch
is admonishing his uh his democrats in
the senate
his colleagues on the other side of the
aisle and telling them that he doesn't
want to hear any lectures
about about conceding elections
immediately and this is very important
because
for a while you saw senate republicans
were being a little timid here were they
going to pull a romney
were they going to pull a jib and can
see the election on trump's behalf or
were they going to stand by trump
which side are you going to be a weak
squishy republican
who is basically just going to play the
court jester and
you know give limp opposition to the
democrat the liberal democratic
ruling regime but then when push comes
to shove you're going to you're going to
lay back
or are you gonna actually fight mitch
mcconnell is gonna actually fight we'll
get them fighting in one second
first though please i would recommend
that you like and subscribe to the
michael knowles show
youtube channel that is where we put our
show out every morning
uh you know they're trying to shut us
down on various social media platforms
particularly right now
since the entire establishment press
is already handing this election to joe
biden and some of us out there are just
not ready to do that because
the facts on the ground don't support
that yet so
big tech is very upset about that make
sure you like and subscribe you may have
already liked and subscribed the youtube
channel
and they may have just unsubscribed to
you so you know give it a little looksie
head on over there and make sure you go
to dailywire.com
especially right now when you can't
trust the establishment press go to
dailywire.com
the replacement media we are coming in
we are going to replace them
and we are not going to call elections
before the elections are over unlike
apparently every single establishment
out go to dailywire.com right now we'll
be right back with a lot more
cocaine mitch has had enough he took to
the senate floor yesterday
and he reminded these democrats with the
attention span of a fruit fly
of how they reacted to the 2016 election
when there was basically no evidence
whatsoever of fraud or irregularities
when there was not yet widespread male
and unsolicited votes
that completely compromised the system
when there was not any of that stuff
and they many of them refused to concede
that election so cocaine mitch
just doesn't want to hear it let's not
have any lectures
no lectures about how the president
should immediately
cheerfully accept preliminary election
results
from the same characters who just spent
four years refusing to accept the
validity of the last election
and who insinuated that this one
would be illegitimate too
if they lost again only if they lost
so let's have no lectures on this
subject from that contention
in late august secretary hillary clinton
said quote
joe biden should not concede under any
circumstances
i think this is going to drag out and he
will win it
if we don't give an inch
that same month speaker pelosi and the
democratic leader both stated quote
president trump needs to cheat
to win in october
when speaker pelosi was shopping some
conspiracy theory about the postal
service
she recklessly said quote listen to this
i have no doubt that the president will
lie cheat and steal to win the election
pretty reckless rhetoric isn't it from
those democrats but now all of a sudden
they say listen we need healing
we need unity we need healing it's let's
come together yeah no i know i was just
i was just threatening you and i know i
spent four years not accepting the
results of the last election and i
i know i told joe biden not to concede
under any circumstances including a
trump landslide
but hey you shouldn't you shouldn't
suspect me of corruption hey
you should come on come on you mean old
republicans oh that that was then this
is now
stop stop uh pursuing this election stop
pursuing the legal
the legal fights implicit in what the
democrats
have been telling us is a threat they
said we're going to blow up the whole
system
right they said we're not going to
concede the election even if we lose
they told us that hillary told us that
jake tapper right now is saying if you
don't concede the election we're going
to ruin your careers
the trump accountability project is
trying to punish
anybody who supported trump or worked
for trump or gave money to trump namely
anybody in any way who has ever helped
donald trump
they want to publish a list of those
people aoc said we need to publish a
list of these people
go out and punish them for what they've
done
and now we're being lectured on
propriety well
cocaine mitch says i don't think so and
by the way they've been physically
threatening us for six months now or
more
seven months do you remember the riots
mr cocaine does
at this time last week small business
owners in cities across america
were boarding up their windows in case
president trump appeared to win
and far-left mobs decided to reprise
their summer
rioting suffice it to say a few legal
inquiries from the president
do not exactly spell the
end of the republic la is still boarded
up i walk up and down the streets in los
angeles there are still boards on the
buildings now none of the stores have
been looted or or
or mobbed or broken down or set up on
fire why not because the left thinks
that joe biden won
that's why and conservatives you'll be
shocked to hear don't riot
they don't loot they don't go steal
gucci bags to mark presidential
elections that they lose
that was the threat we have the evidence
of these physical threats these
essential threats against
the integrity of our elections all
around us in our major cities
and now the left is going to lecture us
about propriety and civility
i don't think so buddy i don't think so
doesn't move me
at all but joe biden is acting as though
he has in fact
already won you have one of the obama
era flunkies ben
rhodes who is he was a big force behind
the iran deal and other
very disastrous foreign policies under
barack obama
he is now describing how biden the
transition has begun and joe biden is
talking to leaders around the world
the trump people seem to be talking like
they have some agency here
we're going to have the pageantry
already of the president-elect
announcing his advisory board
he's going to start announcing cabinet
secretaries the center of political
gravity in this country in the world is
shifting to joe biden
foreign leaders are already having phone
calls with joe biden talking about the
agenda they're going to pursue january
20th
if that reality hasn't sunk in yet for
some people in the white house it will
sink in
when they have to leave on january 20th
we'll see if they have to leave maybe
they do maybe they don't we don't know
yet
mr rhodes the one thing i do know though
the one thing i do know and i think he
accidentally let that slip
is that joe biden is doing
the very things that the trump
transition did that got them thrown in
jail
that got them hauled before a court of
law
ben rhodes just said that joe biden is
speaking to leaders around the world
joe biden is not the president
he's not even the president-elect
although he certainly thinks that he
you remember michael flynn michael flynn
was going to be donald trump's national
security advisor
michael flynn had his life ruined by the
deep state because michael flynn as the
incoming nsa had the audacity
to speak to foreign leaders to do the
exact same thing
that biden and the apparently the biden
transition team
is doing do we think joe biden is going
to get
thrown in prison for that halt before
these he can't do it
he's violating the logan act you know
they people always bring up the logan
act which is this
almost certainly unconstitutional very
old law that says the private u.s
citizens can't
negotiate with with foreign leaders and
it's it's mostly been ignored one it's a
violation of free speech is how it's
typically been viewed
but also it would mean that transition
teams can't do anything
and so no one ever actually fights this
i mean if that were the case john kerry
would be rotting in a prison cell right
now he'd be in alcatraz because john
kerry has continued to negotiate
sometimes out in the open with foreign
leaders especially in iran
after trump came in and ripped up that
stupid iran deal
so joe biden is doing that already i
wonder if we should pose some legal
challenges to that
if i were mike flynn i'd be very upset
right now i might think
that this is not a fair fight that the
system is set up against
republicans that the system is set up to
defend democrats
that the whole system the bureaucracy
the administrative state maybe the
people counting the ballots i don't know
we've got a lot of sworn affidavits
about it
meanwhile bad news from some of the
biden advisors some of them are really
really bad in fact one of the top
advisors that joe biden is tapping
to lead him on coronavirus if joe biden
should become president is a guy named
zeke emanuel
zeke emanuel is the brother of ari
emanuel the hollywood super agent
and he's the brother of rahm emanuel
former chief of staff at the white house
former mayor of chicago pretty
disastrous
zeke emanuel was one of the guys who
brought us obamacare
zeke emanuel is a guy who said we're
gonna be locked down for years which i
guess turns out he was right
one thing people don't really know about
him is zeke emmanuel has a fixation with
death
there are some people right now who are
in the field of scientific research that
pursues
uh life extension how much longer people
can live you know i guess
i guess all of medical science in a way
is pursuing life extension
so that we don't die of diseases at 30
you know that could be cured and you
could go on to live to 80 or 85 years
old
zeke emanuel a few years ago was about
six years ago published a piece in the
atlantic
called why i hope to die at 75
subheader an argument that society and
families and you
will be better off if nature takes its
course swiftly and promptly says 75
that's how long i want to live
75 years my this dr this
drives my daughters crazy they think i
can't mean what i say that i haven't
clearly thought about this because there
is so much in the world to see and do to
convince me of my errors they enumerate
the myriad people i know who are over 75
and doing quite well
i'm sure of my position doubtless death
is a loss
it deprives us of all the things we
value but here is a simple truth that
many of us seem to resist
living too long is also a loss and he
talks about how you know living too long
is kind of humiliating
we know you've got to use a cane you've
got you can't do things as well
your memory slips a little bit so he
wants to die
democrats seem to want to die
there is a culture of death that
pervades the left they want to kill
babies before they're born they want to
kill old people as they become infirm
they support
euthanasia which is assisted suicide for
older people
a morally hideous concept and
they they want to uh off themselves at a
certain point
or not pursue reasonable life-saving
treatment
so i've heard from some people they say
yes we should die earlier
because it's better for the environment
say we should die earlier because it's
better for the economy
die earlier because it's less of a
burden on our families all hideous
hideous stuff
a reminder here that first of all
science rests on
philosophical and theological premises
that's what the basis of it is
we don't we only have science because of
those premises
and science as we think of it today this
very narrow field of material inquiry
cannot provide us necessarily with those
premises it assumes them
and the people who are coming in the
experts the advisors here
have some pretty perverse premises do
you really want a guy
who is hoping that people will die at 75
to come in as a top adviser to treat a
virus
where the median victim is 80 years old
five years after he thinks people should
die
uh that doesn't sound so great to me
sounds like some of their
their vision of the world is a little
messed up and i think that's true
probably across
the prospective biden administration
even as he's counting his votes before
they've come in and maybe some other
people were counting votes
before they came in too or before they
were see
dubbed to be legitimate i'm very pleased
to be able to say that joe biden is not
yet the president-elect because the
thought of having guys
like zeke emmanuel in charge of diseases
not a good thing
the idea of having guys like ben rhodes
in charge of foreign policy
not a good thing fortunately though this
has not been decided yet and some crazy
news out of politics
aoc says she might leave politics the
future of the democratic party
according to the dnc chairman tom perez
might leave politics she just gave an
interview
to the new york times she said i
genuinely don't know
i don't even know if i want to be in
politics you know for real in the first
six months of my term
i didn't even know if i was going to run
for re-election this year it's the
incoming it's the stress it's the
violence it's the lack of support from
your own party
it's your own party thinking you're the
enemy but i'm serious when i tell people
the odds of me running for higher office
and the odds of me
just going off trying to start a
homestead somewhere they're probably the
same says aoc
now at the same time aoc is angling
herself to try to enter the cabinet if
joe biden
is named the president so
people in politics do this all the time
they say uh sir senator senator are you
considering running for president
well now i just love the job i'm doing i
don't know if i want to run for
president you know
sir sir are you thinking ready for
congress now listen i love being a small
business owner
but if my country called me to serve
maybe i would right so there's this long
tradition in politics of pretending that
you're not interested in politics
even though obviously you are that's why
you were in the political arena
so i don't i don't really take aoc's
comments at face value
but i do believe that she's had enough
of congress
i don't think aoc particularly enjoys
being in congress that much
i think she is being stymied in things
that she wants to do i think congress is
a total grind
i think you got to spend most of your
money most of your time rather raising
money
i think you got to travel back and forth
to that district a lot i think as lbj
said the difference between
the senate and congress is the
difference between chicken salad
and chicken excrement and i think that's
all probably true and aoc knows it and
frankly i don't even know that she wants
to be in the senate because the senate
can't get very much done either
but someone tells me she wouldn't mind
being in that cabinet if joe biden is
elected president
something tells me she's angling for
that and that's very
dangerous because right now aoc still
has i guess some sort of democratic
accountability to the people
but with the growth of the liberal
progressive administrative state
more and more you have these czars
implemented you have people
who come in and run departments who have
basically no accountability to the
people at all
and who are able to effectively write
the laws that govern us
without any kind of vote without even
the public knowing very much about it
that's what you're going to see if joe
biden is elected president there will be
a massive growth
in the administrative apparatus and who
could be in charge of it
my goodness gracious you could even get
people like
aoc in there the stakes are very high
that's why it's very important
not to concede a single thing until the
legal process plays out
until the legal ballots are are counted
un until the legal illegal ballots are
thrown out or until the court stops the
whole process
because time has run out there is no
reason though to make a hasty concession
right now
there is a lot on the line i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knoll show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton